WAI CHEE DIMOCK: Just
getting started.
And just want to remind you,
refresh your memory about what
we were talking about
before the break.
So we were talking about
first, the concept of
strangers and kindness of
strangers that Lena would be a
recipient of.
And then we were talking about
neighbors and what could come
to us from neighbors and
not always good things.
And Hightower is a recipient of
the not always good things
coming from our neighbors.
But Hightower, as we also know,
is very emphatic that in
spite of what happens to him,
in spite of the beatings and
so on, that he's actually
surrounded by two people.
So it really takes a tremendous
act of willpower to
be able to say that.
And so this is the quote
from Hightower.
"They are good people.
All that any man can hope for
is to be permitted to live
quietly around his fellows."
So it is a proposition, a
statement that really is sort
of thrown in our face and in
the face of all the things
that have happened to him.
So today what I'd like to do is
to use race as a test case
for Hightower's proposition.
We all know that Joe Christmas
is someone whose racial
identity is ambiguous, I would
say, from beginning to end.
We don't really know for sure
what his parentage --
we have good guesses, but
we don't know for sure.
And we certainly don't know the
genetic makeup of someone
like Joe Christmas.
So in that context, I think it's
especially relevant to
talk about some of
the contemporary
discussion of race.
And this is not even so new.
It came out in 2003.
It was a special issue of
Scientific American, whether
race exists,
and it makes a strong argument
that race is misleading in the
sense that when you look at the
physical characteristics,
the facial features of people,
and we assume that race has a
very solid existence,
that is real.
But actually the facial
characteristics or the
physical attributes do not
always correspond to our
genetic makeup.
So how people look actually is
not a great way to tell us who
they are biologically.
And so the scientific argument
in the special issue or that
essay is about the importance of
thinking outside of the box
of noticeable or observable
visible characteristics, to
thinking about what would
come into play
in a medical situation.
This is Scientific American
after all.
So this was back in 2003.
And even earlier than that,
on the front cover of Time
Magazine, is the new
face of America.
And it's really about America
becoming a mixed-race nation.
And if that is the case, I look
at everyone, yeah, quite
often I can't really tell what
background, ethnic background
people are from.
And that is the case.
This is a computer-generated
image.
And we don't really know.
She's made up of the traits
of many races, and so
it's hard to tell.
But she's a very typical
American face.
And around the same time, a
book came out by F. James
Davis called Who is Black?
Actually this was quite an
important book when it came
out in 1992, to such an extent
that in its 10th anniversary,
PBS actually did a special
program titled Who is Black?
and featured that book.
And his argument is very, very
pertinent to Faulkner's novel.
We don't actually know who
is black in this novel.
So it is a question that
is not answered.
And it's perhaps not meant to be
answerable, even at the end
of the novel.
And this is an image
that actually Tai
used for her section.
And it was a great section.
I'm very happy to be there.
So I just borrowed
it from her.
And this is an Ebony Magazine
quiz, 1952.
But even back in 1952, people
were realizing that if you
look at people, you
don't really know
what race they are.
And so I think that most people
would actually get a
few wrong answers
for that quiz.
So I think that all this is just
to set the stage for the
very complicated and maybe not
meant to be resolved landscape
that Faulkner has set up for us
in Light in August. And so
what I'd like to talk about
today is the word nigger.
And of course, that's the word
that would have to be used.
Because just as in the '50s,
the word negro was the
standard term.
In the '20s and '30s, "nigger"
would have been
the standard term.
So it was not originally
a racial slur.
The use of the word "nigger,"
even though it wasn't
necessarily a racial slur,
it nonetheless
was a charged epithet.
It always has carried excessive
semantic burden.
And because it carries excessive
semantic burden, it
also opens itself up
to multiple uses.
So today we'll look at the way
that word is being used by
different people in different
contexts and
for different purposes.
So we'll go down the list. We'll
be talking about all
this, and also spoken
by other people.
And also when the word is spoken
by the person himself.
So I just noticed this
microphone has a way of
diminishing itself.
So these are the people that
we'll be looking at who use
the word nigger.
First is Joe Brown, and then
the dietitian a couple of
times, and then Hightower, and
then Bobbie the waitress, and
then Joanna Burden.
And then Joe Christmas himself,
he uses the word
nigger for himself.
But first, let's look at the way
Joe Brown uses that word.
At this point, Joe
Brown is being
questioned by the sheriff.
So we know that Joanna's body
has been discovered.
Her house has burned down.
And the sheriff is questioning
Joe Brown.
And there's $1,000 that is
up for anyone who can
help solve the case.
So Joe Brown has sort of high
hopes that he'll be the one to
get the $1,000.
But as the sheriff questions
him, more and more comes out,
it seems less and less likely
that the $1,000 will be in his
own pocket.
So he's getting desperate.
And that is when that
word comes up.
"Because they said it was like
he had been saving what he
told them next for just
such a time as this.
Like he had knowed that
if come to a pinch"--
this is Brian telling
Hightower--
"like he had knowed that if it
come to a pinch, this would
save him, even if it was almost
worse for a white man
to admit what he would have to
admit than to be accused of
the murder itself.
'That's right,' he says.
'Go on.
Accuse me.
Accuse the white man that's
trying to help you
with what he knows.
Accuse the white man and
let the nigger go free.
Accuse the white and
let nigger run.'"
So this is the classic
race card that we
recognize so well.
And unfortunately, it still
has some currency.
So he's playing the race card,
because he's really desperate.
What is really interesting is
how subtle this portrait, even
of someone like Joe Brown
who has so little
saving grace to him.
This is really someone who
is supremely unlikable.
But even for someone who is
supremely unlikable, Faulkner,
nonetheless, portrays him as
someone who's not incapable of
feeling ashamed.
So it is shameful, even for
someone like Joe Brown to use
the race card, that when there's
nothing else he can
do, he would do that.
So he's not such a racist or
such a whatever that he's
blind to what he's doing.
And so I would say that even
though this is Joe Brown doing
one of the despicable things
that he's capable of doing, in
the very act of doing that, he
recognizes completely that he
is being despicable.
So this is one kind of
self-contained usage of
shameful, and shameful even to
the person who is doing it.
And the next couple
of usages all
revolving around the dietitian.
And we know that Joe Christmas
is behind the curtains and
watching this whole scene
unfolding between the
dietitian and her beau and
eating toothpicks and having
no idea what's going on outside
of the dietitian
thinking that he knows
everything.
So she drags him out.
And this is what Joe sees
when she drags him out.
"A face no longer smooth
pink-and-white surrounded now
by wild and disheveled hair
whose smooth band once made
him think of candy. 'You little
rat!' the thin, furious
voice hissed, 'You little rat!
Spying on me!
You little nigger bastard!'"
So she's never called
him that before.
So it's at this moment of
extreme vulnerability on the
part of the dietitian
that that word would
come rushing up.
So it has some relation to the
Joe Brown usage in the sense
that this is a word that comes
out when your back is against
the wall, basically.
This is the thing that
you fling at people.
But the dietitian
actually is more
resourceful than Joe Brown.
She actually is able
to use that word
in some other contexts.
So this is the next installment
of the word nigger
coming out of the mouth
of the dietitian.
And she has something else
to offer Joe Christmas.
Her hand is outstretched, and
upon it lay a silver dollar.
"Her voice went on urgent,
tense, fast. 'A whole dollar.
See?
How much you could buy.
Some to eat every
day for a week.
And next month maybe I'll give
another one.' He seemed to see
ranked tubes of toothpaste like
corded wood, endless and
terrifying; his whole being
coiled in a rich and
passionate revulsion.
'I don't want no
more,' he said.
'I don't ever want no
He didn't need to look
up to know what her
face looked like now.
'Tell!' she said. 'Tell, then!
You little nigger bastard!
You nigger bastard!'"
So this is the evolution of the
dietitian, that she's not
so vulnerable now.
That she's actually on the
verge of going on the
offensive, but not quite.
Because she just wants
to make peace really.
She has wanted to cut a deal
with Joe Christmas, basically.
And so what she doesn't
understand is that he doesn't
understand the concept
of bribery.
Joe Christmas is really
interesting in that way.
He doesn't always understand
kindness.
And he even doesn't understand
the next thing down I think,
which is bribery.
So for him, the silver dollar
just means endless tubes of
toothpaste.
That can't be more
repugnant to him.
But he knows enough to know
that rejecting that silver
dollar would actually be an
automatic guarantee of the
appearance of that word
from the dietitian.
So a pattern is beginning
to develop.
First, complete vulnerability on
the part of the dietitian.
Then not complete vulnerability,
but her scheme
is being foiled unwittingly
by Joe Christmas.
And that word comes out again.
So it's sort of a handy, part
involuntary, but part
reflexive and part handy,
almost instrumental,
usage of that term.
And we'll move on now
to a completely
instrumentalized usage.
So with the dietitian
it begins with a
non-instrumentalized
involuntary usage.
By the third time she uses that
word, it is completely
instrumentalized and completely
calculated.
And that's when the dietitian
goes to the matron of the
orphanage and uses that word,
"nigger," one more time.
"'How did you know about this?'
The dietitian did not
look away. 'I didn't.
I had no idea at all.
Of course I knew it didn't mean
anything when the other
children called him nigger.'
'Nigger?' the matron said.
'The other children?' 'They
had been calling
him nigger for years.
Sometimes I think the children
have a way of knowing things
that grown people of your
and my age don't see.'"
Down to that little detail,
'people of your and my age.'
They actually are not
the same age.
So when you have somebody
using that kind of
construction, you just know
that they're highly
manipulative and know exactly
what they're doing.
So that little giveaway detail
at the end is basically just
the icing on the cake of this
racialization, this very
deliberate racialization of Joe
Christmas in order to get
him sent away from
the orphanage.
So the dietitian, I would say,
is probably right up there, in
my mind, along with Joe Brown
in terms of unlikeability.
But she is better, I think,
at what she's doing.
So she succeeds in pinning that
epithet on Joe Christmas.
And so this is really the first
thing that we should say
about that epithet is that it is
something that someone else
pins on you.
It doesn't really rule
from inside you.
It is not a genetic attribute
about you.
It's an attribution.
It's not an internal genetic
congenital attribute.
It is an attribution that
is foisted upon you.
And that is what the dietitian
is doing right there.
So that is the usage of the word
"nigger" on one side of
the spectrum, Joe Brown
and the dietitian.
And now we'll move on to the
other end of the spectrum
where there's sheer agony
to use that word.
By the time the dietitian uses
the word the last time, she's
actually very good at
what she's doing.
It doesn't really touch
her anymore.
She's completely distanced
herself and therefore able to
manipulate that word.
But here is, on the other side
of the spectrum, someone who
simply cannot have that distance
from that word.
And so it's an agonized usage.
And this comes up in the context
of a conversation
between Hightower and Byron.
And Byron is telling him about
this new development--
about burning down the house,
Joanna's body and so on--
but also about Christmas.
"'About Christmas.
About yesterday and Christmas.
Christmas is part nigger.
About him and Brown and
yesterday.' 'Part negro,'
Hightower says.
His voice sounds light, trivial,
like a thistle bloom
falling into silence without a
sound, without any weight.
He does not move.
For a moment longer,
he does not move.
Then there seems to come over
his whole body as if its parts
were mobile like face features,
that shrinking and
denial, and Byron sees that the
still, flaccid, big face
is suddenly slick with sweat.
But his voice is
light and calm.
'What about Christmas and Brown
and yesterday?' he says.
So it is that utter disparity
between the bodily gesture,
the facial expression, the
bodily expression on
Hightower, and the still
controlled, lightness of tone.
That is what gives
Hightower away.
That not only is the possibility
of Joe Christmas
being black, not only is it
the most terrifying of
possibilities, but it's so
terrifying that he can't
really afford to acknowledge
its gravity.
So it's not just that it's just
terrible, but he can't
even admit to it.
It's that double combination
that suggests just how grave
the situation is.
Because Hightower knows exactly
what's going to happen.
Once the question of race
comes into play, there's
probably just one outcome.
He knows it from his own
personal history from what has
happened to him and to his
cook, and that was really
nothing compared with this.
So it's just a terrible
scenario, the endpoint of
which he can already see, and
that's why he's behaving in
this particular way.
But there's also a point, kind
of a division, the lightness
of tone and kind of the
involuntary shrinking and
sweating and just kind
of devastation
that's coming over Hightower.
It points to the doubleness
of Hightower.
And I think it's worth
talking about.
This is a slight digression.
But Faulkner's really very
emphatic about the two faces
of Hightower.
I think sometimes we tend to see
him too much as a victim,
and certainly what's happened to
him invites us to think of
him as just a victim of his
neighbor's violence.
But Faulkner is empathic
from beginning to
end that he is two-faced.
"His face is at once gaunt at
flabby; it is as though there
were two faces, one imposed upon
the other, looking out
from beneath the pale, bald
skull surrounded by a fringe
of gray hair, from behind the
twin motionless glare of his
spectacles."
Down to the twin glares of his
spectacle, to an earlier
moment where everybody's coming
out of the church and
the reporters were taking a
picture of him, and they took
picture of him from the side.
He looks like Satan.
Down to this moment when this
lightness of tone is belied by
the involuntary shrinking
of his body.
Hightower seems to be the
meeting place for two
contradictory impulses.
And so we can also say that
metaphorically, he's also the
meeting place for the goodness
of strangers and the brutality
of the neighbors.
He really is a kind of
unresolved meeting place for
those two cross-currents.
But right now, right there
he's trying his best to
trivialize that event in saying
that it really is
nothing at all.
It is of no consequence.
Coming now to Bobbie the
waitress, we'll look at one
instance, another instance of
someone trying to trivialize
that fact, the possibility
that Joe could be black.
So this is the two of
them lying in bed.
And he makes this confession.
"'I got some nigger blood in
me.' Then she lay perfectly
still, with a different
stillness.
But he did not seem
to notice it.
He lay peacefully too,
his hand slow up
and down her flank.
'You're what?' she said. 'I
think I got some nigger blood
in me.' His eyes were closed,
his hand slow and unceasing.
'I don't know.
I believe I have.'
She did not move.
She said at once, 'You're
lying.' 'All right.' he said,
not moving, his hand
not ceasing.
'I don't believe it.' her voice
said in the darkness."
So I think that Faulkner is
going out of his way to make
this a very peaceful scenario.
So this is the equivalent of
that lightness of tone that
Hightower is using when he is
facing the possibility that
Joe Christmas is black.
And here, Joe Christmas is
making that confession
himself, but really
he doesn't know.
But all the emphasis here is on
how peaceful the scene is.
He's just stroking her.
He doesn't stop when he
makes that confession.
So it's as if nothing
is happening.
It wants to create the illusion
that nothing is happening.
But actually, everything
is happening.
So the waitress Bobbie's
reaction goes along with the
pretense that this is really
nothing at all.
She's not going to
believe in it.
There's nothing to it.
But we also know that that takes
a lot of willpower, that
that assertion, 'I don't
believe it' or
there's nothing to it.
You're just imagining it.
All those statements actually
take a lot of
willpower to say.
And how superficial that the
assertion is becomes clear
when something else happens.
And then Bobbie uses the word
nigger one more time.
This time in a completely
different tone of voice.
This is much later when Joe
has killed everything.
He has killed his foster
father in the kitchen
accidentally.
And now he's going to see
Bobbie one more time.
And now they know that they have
to leave, that they're in
big trouble.
So this is a moment of duress,
the equivalent of the
dietitian's duress,
the equivalent
of Joe Brown's duress.
And this is what Bobbie
says under duress.
"It was very much like it had
been in the school house,
someone holding her as she
struggled and shrieked, her
hair wild with the jerking and
tossing of her head, her face,
even her mouth, in contrast with
the hair, as still as a
bad mouth in a dead face.
'Bastard Son of a bitch!
Getting me into a jam, that
always treated you
like a white man.
A white man!' Perhaps Joe did
not hear her at all, nor the
screaming waitress.
'He told me himself
he was a nigger!
The son of a bitch!
Me F-word for nothing a nigger
son of a bitch that would get
me in a jam with clodhopper
police.'"
So this not by design.
It is involuntary usage.
But it is telling that that's
the word that always, or at
least every single one,
everything single character in
Light in August would
reach for.
That is the word that would come
involuntarily into our
mouths when we are
under duress.
It also says that no matter what
good intentions we have
or how much willpower we hope
to bring to bear on a
racialized situation, that that
willpower is always going
to be unequal to the terrible
weight, cementing weight that
comes with that word.
That every individual effort to
lighten or trivialize that
epithet, every attempt to make
light of it is going to fail.
This is probably another
possible meaning for Light in
August that this is an attempt
of various people to make
light of the phenomenon of
race and not succeeding.
So Bobbie is, in that sense,
not even an especially
interesting character on her
own, other than as a kind of a
dramatizing, concentrated
version of the sort of
involuntary reactions and
involuntary usage of that word
when we ourselves are
under duress.
And all this really quite
marginal thing that
Hightower--
isn't all that marginal--
but his reaction, in many ways,
is an entry point to his
psychology.
But there's one person for
whom the word "nigger" is
front and center, and in many
ways she is more extreme to be
a generalized case.
So Faulkner uses Joanna Burden
as a fairly atypical case of
thinking, very emotional
response to the word "nigger."
That it's, in many ways, on the
far end of the spectrum,
that nonetheless reflects on
the medium, on the mean of
that spectrum.
But she has this very extreme
notion of what the word
"nigger" means, which is that
it is an eternal curse, and
the context of which is the
death of her grandfather and
her half-brother Calvin.
So her grandfather and her
half-brother Calvin were
killed by a white person.
They were killed by Satoris.
So let's not forget
that they were not
killed by a black person.
They were killed by
a white person.
But this is the account that
Joanna would give of the
reason why the two of
them are killed.
This is what the father
says to her.
"'Your grandfather and brother
are lying there, murdered not
by one white man, but by the
curse which God put on a whole
race before your grandfather or
your brother or me or you
were ever thought of.
A race doomed and cursed to be
forever and ever a part of the
white race's doom and
curse for its sins.
Remember that.
His doom and his curse.
Forever and ever.
Mine.
Your mother's.
Yours, even though
you are a child.
The curse of every white child
that was born and that ever
will be born.
None can escape it."
This is about as thoroughgoing
a curse as could be.
It's basically comprehensive,
cover all the bases.
It covers every single member of
the white race, and it goes
on for an eternity.
That curse will never go away.
So why is it that when two white
people are killed by
another white person that that
is the case of the curse of
the black race?
That is a really interesting
bit of logic.
But Joanna's father is
firmly convinced
that that is the case.
That if there had not been
blacks in this world--
which actually probably
would have been true--
if there had not been blacks in
this world, the grandfather
and Calvin would not have
been killed by Satoris.
So even though it seems like a
strange kind of logic, once
you spell it out in that way,
actually it is a strange, but
nonetheless truthful
statement.
And this is how Joanna's
interpretation of that
statement, her elaboration on
that image of race as an
eternal curse on the blacks,
obviously, but also on the
whites as well.
And given what her father
says, this is
what she herself thinks.
"But after that I seemed to see
them--" blacks-- "for the
first time not as people, but as
a thing, a shadow in which
I live, we lived, all white
people, all other people.
I thought of all the children
coming forever and ever in the
world, white, with a black
shadow already falling upon
them before they drew breath.
And I seemed to see the
black shadow in
the shape of a cross.
And it seemed like the white
babies were struggling, even
before they drew breath to
escape from the shadow, that
was not only upon them but
beneath them too, flung out
like their arms were flung
out, as if they were
nailed to the cross.
I saw all the little babies
that would ever be in the
world, the ones not yet even
born-- a long line of them
with their arms spread,
on the black cross."
So this is a modern
interpretation of an entire
race being crucified.
And it turns out that according
to Joanna and her
father that the dynamics of race
and the legacy of slavery
is such that whites will be
crucified upon the black cross
for as long as they live, for
as long as they are human
beings on earth.
So it's an extravagant claim.
And it's predicated on the
notion, and in some sense,
it's a summary of all that we've
seen so far, which is
that the racial epithet is in
fact an epithet that all of us
reach for involuntarily when
we are under duress.
So it's almost a kind of
psychological necessity for us
to call someone black.
That all of us as human beings,
because all of us are
under duress so much of the
time, there's just no way to
avoid being under duress
some of the time.
Because there's such good
chances for all of us to be
under duress, there also good
chances for all of us to call
someone black.
We just need to make that kind
of attribution on someone.
And it's because of that basic
human psychological need that
the relations between the
races-- so-called races, even
though the membership of
each one is always
going to be in flux--
but the relation between the
supposed races, that relation
is always going to be fraught,
always going to
be a terrible relation.
And that's why, according to
Joanna, it's not just the
black shadow falling on white
babies, but she actually goes
so far as to say that
that shadow is
underneath them as well.
This is an incredibly detailed,
all-encompassing
black shadow that basically
envelops everyone.
So it's on top of you.
It's underneath you.
You arms are flung out, and it
follows the shape of your
arms. Basically, it completely
envelops every inch of you.
There's no escape from
that black curse.
So this is really an
incredible claim.
And I think that it's helpful,
in order to contextualize that
claim, to think about the
Burden genealogy.
I'm sure Faulkner would object
to this kind of schematic
summary, but this is what we
have. The Burden geneaology
starts up with someone called
Nathaniel Burrington.
It's changed to Burden by
Calvin Burden who has a
Huguenot Protestant
wife and friends.
And then Nathaniel Burden joined
his father with two
wives, the Mexican wife Juana or
Joanna, and a wife from New
Hampshire who's Joanna's
extra mother.
And then Calvin Burden, his
son, first son killed by
Satoris along with
the grandfather
and then Joanna Burden.
So this is the Burden
genealogy.
And we'll see that two names
are being repeated twice.
So the name Nathaniel
appears twice.
And the name Calvin
Definitely Faulkner loves
to play with names.
So this is another instance of
the nontrivial play with
names,
because we all know who Calvin
is, and he has everything to
say about original sin
and predestination.
John Calvin right there, looking
like someone who would
make that kind of statement
about original sin.
And this is his treatise,
Calvin, Institutes of the
Christian Religion.
And this is what he says
about original sin.
"Original sin, therefore,
seems to be a hereditary
depravity and corruption of our
nature, diffused into all
parts of the soul, which first
makes us liable to God's
wrath."
So it doesn't really actually
take the reprehensible action
of anyone for us to be liable to
God's wrath, that actually
we inherit that.
The important thing is that
it is hereditary.
It is passed on from one
generation to another without
the volition of the person upon
which it is visited and
without even necessarily any
reprehensible action on whom
that original sin is visited.
It simply is something that is
passed on automatically from
one generation to another.
So this a longstanding tradition
of thinking about an
evil that we can't escape, that
we're just involuntarily
signed up on to this legacy of
evil and punishment and curse.
I would say this is Joanna's
genealogy.
And this is also partly
Faulkner's genealogy as well.
I wouldn't say that he's a
Calvinist, but he's certainly
very, very interested in this
kind of thinking, a curse that
is transmitted across time,
across generations.
But there's another
party to this
genealogy, Nathaniel Hawthorne.
We already have seen how
important Hawthorne is.
And it turns out he really is
a figure of longstanding
relevance to Faulkner.
So the Hawthorne-Faulkner
connection.
We know that in The Scarlet
Letter there's the Reverend
Dimsdale who commits adultery
with Hester Prynne.
In As I Lay Dying, there's the
Reverend Whitfield who commits
adultery with Addie.
So Whitfield, Dimsdale, and
Whitfield actually making a
speech that sounds almost like
Dimsdale's speech at the end
of The Scarlet Letter.
And then in Light in August,
the name Nathaniel is
resurrected one more time.
It's almost as if Faulkner's
just paying kind of this late
tribute to an author who's
been very, very
important to him.
And so given the fact that the
Hawthorne connection is
actually a connection by way of
The Scarlet Letter, which
is, in some sense, a novel not
just about sin, some kind of
sin, past sin that Dimsdale
certainly can't shake off and
maybe Hester can't shake off
either, a sin that will stick
to you and follow you
wherever you go.
It's not only just about that,
but it's also about sexual
depravity or sexual license to
some extent, even though that
is not represented at all in
The Scarlet Letter and not
really represented
in any details.
In both those novels, in both
The Scarlet Letter and As I
Lay Dying, the sexual license
is only gestured at.
We know the outcome of that
elicit sexuality in the sense
that we see Hester's
illegitimate daughter Pearl in
The Scarlet Letter, and we see
Addie's illegitimate son
Jewel, and there's also a
connection between Pearl and
Jewel as well.
We see Addie's illegitimate son
Jewel in As I Lay Dying.
But in both those novels the
sexual license is not really
represented.
It's not part of the novel.
In Light in August, actually we
do see that sexual license
front and center.
And what makes this even more
complicated is that it's
mapped onto the platform
of race.
So it is the weird combination
of belief in Calvinist
original sin coupled with sexual
wildness on the part of
Joanna Burden.
And that is when the word
"negro" comes up.
This is yet another of the
licentious context for the use
of the word "negro."
"Now and then she appointed
trysts beneath certain shrubs
about the grounds, where he
would find her naked or with
her clothing half torn to
ribbons upon her in the wild
throes of nymphomania, her
body gleaming in the slow
shifting from one to another
of such formally erotic
attitudes and gestures as a
Beardsley of the time of
Petronius might have drawn.
She would be wild then, in the
close, breathing halfdark
without walls, with her wild
hair, each strand of which
would seem to come alive like
octopus tentacles, and her
wild hands and her breathing,
'Negro!
Negro!
Negro!'"
So it might seem
incomprehensible that someone
like Joanna Burden spends all
her time trying to help blacks
in the south, who is the on the
board of dozen charities
and black schools--
basically has dedicated her
entire life to racial uplift--
should be doing this.
But I think that it actually
is, I think that as far as
Faulkner is concerned, this
incredible sexual license
actually goes hand in hand with
a belief in Calvinist
predestination.
If you really believe that you
are going to be stuck with
original sin, that that is going
to be upon you, that
black shadow is going to be upon
you no matter what you
do, then it doesn't really
matter what you do.
It is a weird kind of
granting of license.
That if you're going to be evil
anyway, no matter what
you do, then you might as well
actually be evil in your
conduct as well.
There's something
of that logic.
But I don't even think that
it's as logical as that.
For Faulkner, it's just the
two sides of Joanna.
And maybe just as Hightower has
two faces, Joanna clearly
has two faces, and the whole
tradition, Calvinist
tradition, also has two faces.
And that is really Faulkner's
contribution to thinking about
this particular kind
of theology.
But we also notice is that
Faulkner tends to stick in all
kinds of weird details into this
otherwise just kind of
full-dressed description
of sexual license
on the part of Joanna.
He also has weird kind of
references to two other
traditions.
One is Beardsley and the
other is Petronius.
So this is Beardsley,
the famous
illustrator, Aubrey Beardsley.
This is Salome, showing human
beings in this kind of very
erotic and wild gestures.
This is another illustration
for Oscar Wilde's Salome.
And as for Petronius, this is
actually not quite a novel.
This is sort of a beginning
of a novel --
Petronius, the writer
of Satyricon.
The reason that it's related to
the Faulkner novels often,
especially Light in August, is
that this early novel is about
two foreigners with
Greek-sounding names,
Encolpius and Giton
in Southern Italy.
So this is the first instance
of northerners going south.
Not quite Yankees
going south to
Mississippi, but similar
dynamics.
And Joanna and her father and
the whole family knows that
they're hated as Yankees
and carpetbaggers as
we've seen last time.
So the whole dynamics of people
from one region going
south and being hated
by the locals.
But in this case, there's this
additional complication.
That this is a very cold
northerner going to the hot
south, and in some instances,
being heated up by that
tropical environment.
But basically staying
cold and hot.
So this is the pendulum swing of
Joanna from that incredible
sexual license to
the other side.
And she also, interestingly
enough, she also uses the word
"negro" in that context when she
swings to the other side.
"She was sitting quite still on
the bed, her hands on her
lap, her still New England face
(it was still the face of
a spinster, prominently boned,
long, a little thin, almost
manlike; in contrast to it her
plump body was more richly and
softly animal than
ever) lowered.
She said in a tone
musing, detached,
impersonal, 'A full measure.
Even to a bastard negro child.
I would like to see father's
and Calvin's faces.'"
The syntax I think is very
interesting, that what is in
the parentheses, the still face
of the spinster and then
the animal body, are kind of a
perfect summary of the two
sides of Joanna.
Even for Faulkner, it's
very ungainly syntax
or deliberate syntax.
And then that last part of that,
the bastard negro child.
And is not accidental that
this is the moment where
suddenly she's invoking
Calvin.
I would like to see father
Nathaniel's face
and Calvin's face.
This is almost as if this is
the new twentieth century
edition to The Scarlet Letter
and the new twentieth century
edition to the longstanding
theology of Calvin.
That this is what happens when
you inherit from those two
traditions is that you
both do good by
supposedly helping blacks.
But then you also engage in
this uncontrollable sexual
orgy with them.
And the bastard negro child is
this kind of also involuntary
outcome of the union
of those two sides.
And so it's sort of easy to see
why Joanna is not going to
be an easy person for Joe
Christmas to deal with.
Anyone would have a hard time
trying to negotiate, trying to
deal with someone like that.
And Joe Christmas' response
is like this.
At this point, Joanna wants
him to go to school.
Wants him to study law with a
black lawyer and wants to turn
over all her funds, all the
money that she has.
And it's not insignificant.
She wants to turn over
all the money to him,
and this is his response.
"'To school.' his mouth said.
'A nigger school.
Me.' 'Yes.
Then you can go to Memphis.
You can read law in
Peebles' office.
He will teach you law.' 'And
then learn law in the office
of a nigger lawyer,'
his mouth said.
'Yes.
Then I will turn over
all the business to
you, all the money.
All of it.
So that when you need money
for yourself, you could...
you would know how; lawyers know
how to do it so they...
You would be helping them out
of darkness and none could
accuse or blame you even if they
found out.' 'But a nigger
college, a nigger lawyer,' his
voice said, quiet, not even
argumentative; just promptive.
They were not looking at one
another; she had not looked up
since he entered.
'Tell them,' she said.
'Tell niggers that I'm
a nigger too?'"
Especially this is a moment when
Joanna is both completely
tone deaf, but also just an
incredibly sad person.
That this is the best
she can do for him.
She's too embarrassed.
She's trying to bribe
him as well.
She's trying to say I'm
going to turn over all
the money to you.
And it really doesn't matter
if you study law.
You know how to use the money
for your pleasure, really.
She can't really bring herself
to say that word.
She wants to do the
most for him.
And she will not admit to it.
She would not name what she's
turning over to him.
So all the ellipses of those
unfinished sentences.
She's both tone deaf, but also
actually at the maximum point
of goodwill and love maybe even
towards him, wanting to
do the most for him.
And his way of responding is by
being totally ironic about
the word "nigger" and obviously
about her as well.
So I think that we can say when
the word "nigger" is used
in that context, it's
also a moment of
psychological duress.
That maybe he just even can't
bear to acknowledge the fact
that she wants to do
so much for him.
I think that that would be
one way to read that.
That this is actually not a
moment when there's no love
felt or that that
romance is over.
It's not that.
But that maybe it's too much.
And that the way that he's
responding to that is by being
totally cynical, satirical and
ironic about the whole thing.
So this scene is really open
to any number of readings.
All we know that it is
definitely not an innocent
word when it's used
by oneself.
That it is as charged and as
painful to use as when it is
attributed to oneself
by other people.